unlv is helping kids get ready to go  back to the classroom  the school of medicine held an  immunization clinic this morning  not only were kids able to get their  shots updated but school supplies were  also available  as we continue to battle through this  pandemic health officials say it's  important to cover all of our bases  the regular vaccines are very important  especially when going back to school  we don't want to forget those because  there's always the risk of  having certain diseases like measles and  pertussis  so we want to make sure that we don't  have another outbreak of other viruses  and so i think that you know we're  trying to be proactive for families to  get  vaccinated if you missed out there'll be  another immunization clinic in september  we'll be sure to keep you up to date on  those details